E aí
[Música]
se a cozinheira
a babá se a faxineira
a trabalhadora braçal
às vezes até o melhor amiga para
qualquer protagonista mas sempre sempre
a serviçal foi assim que durante muitos
anos eu me enxerguei nas obras impressas
ou audiovisuais a coisa eu gostei bença
tia Nastácia lá na infância até as
emblemáticos empregadas das das novelas
das noves de hoje em dia a mídia
juntamente com a publicidade o marketing
criaram e mantém o estereótipo sobre as
pessoas e suas características beijo a
loira magra que é sinônimo de beleza
doçura a morena de óculos que é super
inteligente a negra magra que a
hipersexualizada E por aí vai até chegar
na preta gorda a quem só lhe restou o
papel E aí
e eu não sei vocês mas olha infância
adolescência na escola
a gente gostava muito de brincar de
fingir que eram os personagens da TV do
cinema gente encontrar alguém parecido
ali e falava eu sou esse personagem eu
tinha muita vergonha porque não tinha
ninguém que eu pudesse ser afinal de
contas não tinha ninguém nas telas que
fosse parecido comigo
e é às vezes até tinha mas eram as
sementes E essas não tinha vida não
tinha narrativas em torno delas não
tinha nada bem mas voltando aos
estereótipos
estando eles devidamente criados agora é
a hora da proliferação deles então
marketing estrategicamente cria suas
publicidades pautadas na Aquelas imagens
que a gente viu ele atrás e como é que o
objetivo é gerar desejo claramente a
mulher que vai ser representado aqui é a
mulher branca a magra aquela doce
inteligente
afinal de contas quem quer estar no
papel de subserviência
e eu sempre fui muito ligada a moda é e
assuntos dígitos como femininos então na
minha adolescência ele é muita daquelas
revistinhas
novelas e séries teens Eu lembro que uma
dessas dessas revistas eu li uma
entrevista
é onde uma atriz-mirim muito famosa
pelos seus cabelos ruivos ali ela
comemorar você os 16 anos na capa de uma
revista Eu lembro que uma das perguntas
direcionadas a ela era sobre um sonho de
um trabalho que ela nunca havia
realizado e ela falou que ela queria
muito fazer um comercial de xampu a
quilos o como uma afirmação da beleza
dela e dos cabelos dela tão comentados E
aí eu lembro que porque senão tempo
depois eu vi essa essa atriz fazendo um
comercial de shampoo e desde então eu
não consigo contar quantos comerciais de
produtos para cabelo que essa moça
apareceu
ou seja o objetivo dela de afirmar a
beleza dos cabelos dela tinha sido
concluído e eu fiquei me questionando
se nós tivéssemos a oportunidade de
também poder falar em algum lugar que
nós temos essa vontade Nós também
Queremos nos ver representada a gente
quer estar no comercial de Shampoo seja
representada na moda com os nossos
corpos
talvez a gente também teria a mesma
oportunidade né
a a inocência da Juventude né
mas enfim Hoje os tempos mudaram né
Graças a Deus hoje com a internet e as
redes sociais a gente consegue ter voz
Nós criamos os nossos próprios conteúdos
nós conseguimos trazer as nossas
reivindicações
colocar em pauta hoje nós mesmo
conseguimos estar na tela né eu posso
pegar a minha tela agora o meu celular o
meu computador eu posso ver uma mulher
tô falando sobre moda uma mulher preta
falando de beleza de culinária de
esporte eu posso estar nessa tela e olha
só hoje faz parte do meu trabalho também
sem representatividade para outras
mulheres como eu hoje é possível termos
voz e nós estamos gritando a nossa
necessidade de representatividade mas
parece que ainda não somos ouvidas ou
somos nós somos pouco ouvidas bem pouco
nas minhas redes sociais eu falo
diariamente de sobre gordofobia
racismo e as pressões estéticas que que
isso nos traz é
as respostas e os diálogos que eu tenho
da minha audiência é justamente sobre
como elas se sentem abraçadas com a
minha presença ali e como isso muitas
vezes consegue mudar o olhar delas para
algo que elas nunca tinham
é possível por nunca ter visto aquilo
representado em corpos como os seus
eu tenho aqui alguns comentários do que
eu recebo quase todos os dias das minhas
redes sociais algumas mensagens eu vou
deixar aqui só para a gente ter um
pouquinho mais da ideia de qual
importante é a representatividade
E aí
o primeiro comentário
"só preconceito todos os dias por ter
seios grandes e não ter o bumbum grande
fala que meu corpo é desproporcional que
não sou uma brasileira padrão já sofri
muito com isso tive depressão Hoje
passou pelo processo de aceitação Estou
matando um leão por dia você para mim é
mais com inspiração Obrigada por ser tão
maravilhosa" mais um
você é minha inspiração pois sou
gordinha e sofro bullying da minha
própria família quando vejo suas fotos
Stories me sinto muito melhor você me
transmite força
Oi e o último agora é tão bom ouvir isso
de quem já passou pelo mesmo que eu
sempre fui muito julgada pelo meu corpo
como se fosse algo público Estou te
seguindo a pouco tempo e Amanda o seu
conteúdo e você
fico feliz de ver tanto a
representatividade
esses São só alguns Dos comentários que
eu recebo diariamente mas isso já tá na
rede há muito tempo a gente já vem
gritando por representatividade já tem
pedindo faz um tempo mas parece que
quanto mais alta a gente grita mais o
marketing EA publicidade tapam os
ouvidos e insistem em manter um velho e
insustentável padrão midiático esse
estereótipo faz com que milhares de
mulheres odeiam seus corpos todos os
dias e sintam-se inadequadas ao olhar no
espelho e confrontar a sua aparência
real a falta de representatividade ela
desumaniza o nosso Oi e a nossa
existência a imagem da mulher preta e
gorda ela vem sendo ligada à
subserviência ausência de beleza de
cuidados de delicadeza a anos é algo que
já está enraizado no Imaginário social e
até considerada a única realidade o
possível para muitas dessas mulheres
o meu papel aqui hoje é o mesmo que
desenvolve nas minhas redes sociais eu
vim propor Um Desafio eu vim desafiar
Você a me olhar para além de um
pacotinho de estereótipos eu te desafio
a tirar essa venda que a mídia colocou
nos seus olhos por tantos anos o desafio
Hoje é você me olhar com humanidade será
que você consegue
é obrigada a
[Música]